we have in our studio today a Turkish
former minister of economy and an
economist of war repute Kemal Darvish
and governor which has just published a
book called a better globalization and
we are going to discuss some of the
things he has treated in the book as
well as issues of great current
importance Oh welcome to the studio
thank you good to be here at you the
first question I'd like to ask you is
this issue of North Korea's declaring to
have nuclear weapon that issue brings
the question of all security right with
the doorstep of the United Nations and
at the United Nations at this stage
seems kind of totally incapable of
healthy handling it because Security
Council is not an imposition to decide
anything so how does one move the world
sort of problem of security if the
Security Council is kind of paralyzed
because of differences that exist
between the five permanent members it's
the heart of the security problem
collective security problem in fact we
discussed this today at the center for
global realization at Yale I think the
Security Council is the only institution
really in the international system that
does have power potential power if you
like but too many times that power is
deadlocked by really the veto power of
individual countries and I think 11
important thesis in the book which has a
lot of support in the world is that one
has to move to a more representative
Security Council but at the same time a
Security Council that works global
democracy cannot be just one country one
vote you cannot have China and Malta
have the same weight in the
international system so one has to have
weighted voting weights that reflect the
size of the
the population and the resources the
country contributes to the international
system and so one proposal is to really
move to Security Council that is more
universal with weighted voting it's
tough because the existing veto holders
of course you know they have it right
they'd only give it up and so it's not
an easy proposition at all but from what
you are suggesting is it doesn't require
the United States or China to give up
the fit o ok well no individual vetoes I
think should maybe not immediately they
can be transition period but 15 20 years
from now and it will be very hard to
justify for example that United Kingdom
which is an important country but of
course compared to India or China or
even Brazil you know it's a small
country and will become smaller in time
that forever it should keep an
individual veto power instead I think
Europe should have enough weight in the
system that a majority weighted majority
voting system would give it de facto
veto power so United States by by its
size population resources could block
important decisions come you know could
in a sense have a way to to to stop
things that it really doesn't want but I
think one has to graduate this it's only
the very very very important decisions
that should be subject to large super
majorities which would give these
important countries blocking power in in
other cases decisions should be made
more easily by simple majorities or
smaller super majorities yeah like ice
would discussed in the book yeah I think
you are saying that for decision to
invade a country to yes you really need
a supermajority four-fifths of the
awaited right that's right that's that's
my proposal now if you can explain a
little bits of what how does the word at
work or not be what are the components
of the way tench well the proposal I
have and of course other things are
possible also but the four weights that
I propose our population very important
in today's world where we want democracy
to triumph you know and we say that
democracy is needs to be support
it can't stop at the borders of the
nation state so population is important
you have to give kind of countries
weight according to their population but
other things also should come GDP the
resources that country has the part of
the resources it contributes to global
public goods and also the capacity for
peacekeeping in the security area its
military capacity to enforce security
should also be one of the way so that's
what I'm proposing and of course whether
one wants to wait this equally or or
give some more weight to one of these
factors is open to debate and you said
that you have support from got a lot of
people well not necessarily the ones
that make the final decisions but you
know I do work with quite a bit of
Social Democrats around the world in
Europe in Latin America there is support
for this kind of system because
conceptually logically if we believe in
collective security if we really believe
in a legitimate system of global
collective security there is really no
alternative to something like that and
you know one of the one of the points
are often make if we had a strong system
of collective security that could have
prevented for example the war in
Yugoslavia or the Iraq war bye-bye joint
collective action that would be you know
that would be have influence events much
more we could have saved maybe 100
billion 200 billion three hundred
billion dollars so it's it's so
important that we get it right you know
in the fight against aids which is very
important we try to mobilize three four
more billion five more billion you know
save hundreds of thousands millions of
people and then when somewhere the
security system breaks down we you know
we have to spend the world as to spend
the American taxpayer the British
taxpayer the Turkish taxpayer you know I
has to spend much much more than that so
it's important and I think citizens
should realize how important it is
prevention costs much less than the
exact you exactly yeah so and the
prevention of course
when things move to a stage one you have
to take military action is one but
before things leader stays there is a
long period when the economy is
collapsing failed states are created and
how do you adjust that question how does
one prevent yeah that's another major
message of course and that is that the
economic social and environmental
aspects of security are deeply
interlinked with the purely military
aspects of security of the physical
aspects of security failed States you
know like Afghanistan was a failed state
led to tremendous catastrophes so there
is there of course in Africa when
governance breaks down you've had
millions of Africans die you had also in
Europe we always say Africa but we
should remember that the tragedy in
Bosnia you know was was in Europe was in
the heart of Europe so to speak so we we
have to look at the economic and social
aspects too and we have to have the
mechanisms by which as you as you say
before it gets to the disaster point you
know one doesn't let the economic and
social situation deteriorate to the
point that then it becomes very costly
to fix it and on the economic side you
know one has to of course distinguish
between different types of countries the
very poor countries are getting some
help they need more they need also much
better governance and the two have to go
together just throwing money at problems
never works we know that you know in
economics we know that so yes money is
needed but it has to be used
appropriately it has to be used within a
system of governance but there's still
many problems even in the middle income
countries in my country in Turkey we
have lots of very poor people in Brazil
in northern Brazil in them in the slums
around the Brazilian cities of course
even in China and India with your
countries that are growing very rapidly
but inequality is a problem quite severe
poverty still remains a problem in these
countries now yeah we have to look at
the you know poverty everywhere not just
in the poorest of the poorest countries
now you are in a very unique position to
address this question raised by many of
the people who oppose globalization is
the heavy-handed intervention by the IMF
or bank and you worked more than 20
years the World Bank and then you are
back in Turkey as a minister of economic
affairs at a time when economy was
collapsing ninety percent of gdp was
going to pay for pain and dates now you
turn it around with the help of IMF and
World Bank and so what would you tell
the critics of IMF and World Bank are
the right or the wrong well I would say
like all international organizations
they are as good to large degree as the
countries that make them up let them be
when we say the IMF does this or the IMF
as does that we often have to remember
that it's the big shareholders the g7
countries that make a lot of the really
important decisions and you know
sometimes it's easy to blame the
organizer or it's the same for the UN
you know it's very easy to say the UN
doesn't do this the UN doesn't do that
but does the UN have the means to do the
things we wanted to do the same Holtz I
think also quite often for the IMF and
the World Bank I think they're important
institutions they they have to step in
in crisis moments very often and people
you know obviously are in difficulties
at that time and sometimes as a as a
tendency sometimes to say that the
difficulty is view to the IMF which I
think the difficulty was there before
however I also strongly believe and I
felt it in Turkey that things have to
change at the IMF the World Bank that
these institutions have to become much
more the institutions also of the
developing countries they cannot remain
under this strong dominance of the g7
the richest country not this dog and
then that change is very important for
those institutions to become more
effective dominance is in terms of
ideology of the Institute in terms of
ideology in terms of governance in terms
of the boards the way they function
you know that makes these institutions
which have tremendous potential to do
useful things it makes them suspect and
it makes them you know illegitimate in
the sense of a large majority of
humanity whether it's in Turkey or in
Brazil or in Argentina or in Indonesia
in India there's no real trust and for
these institutions which have resources
which have you know which have staff
which have technical knowledge to really
be useful fully and to do what they
could do I think we have to make them
more legitimate you have been nothing
room interesting example I think you
have in your book and perhaps talk about
this is the question of farm subsidy
that Turkish farmers were being given
subsidy so that they could the economy
could benefit at the same time the poor
farmers could benefit but then IMF was
opposing it right well there was a yeah
there was an episode where instead of
having price supports we moved to system
of income supports for poor farmers
which is a better system because the
budget resources I directed towards the
poorest people and also priced
structures aren't distorted and
hopefully a better more more viable
agriculture can come out of this but
then an IMF mission came and because
there was the hole in the budget was
looking for something to cut and
together with the government actually
they agreed to cut the direct income
support to the poor farmers okay which I
think was it was a big mistake the World
Bank actually spoke up against it and
said you can't do this you shouldn't do
this we promised the poor farmers this
direct income support and you know
that's how they we transform the system
and we owe it to them to pay these
support so there was a disagreement but
that disagreement which was on substance
of the policy people immediately started
to say oh but that's because you know
the bank is run by an American president
once turkey to be dependent on the US
and things things of that sort which had
nothing to do really with the issues
finally get resolved
well they did cut unfortunately some of
these support but then the economy
improved and we raised hell also in your
position I was at that time in the
addition and the support was reinstated
a few months later so in a sense it got
protected happily you have also talked
about development-oriented World Trade
Organization policy if you can elaborate
on that how do you what I mean how can
well trade is important to the world
economy it's it's something that
potentially increases prosperity it has
worked well for I think you're from
India you know for India India has
benefited from some of the trade from
some of the technologies that have come
has been growing much quite rapidly
lately and china has also benefited from
the global economy by exporting a lot so
it is clear that some developing
countries poor countries can benefit
from trade but at the same time the the
whole mechanism in which trade is being
managed they often powerful interests
try to capture it we saw for example
doing at the end of the way around that
the powerful rich country pharmaceutical
companies introduced certain provisions
about intellectual property rights that
were excessive and that we're really not
reasonable and in a way captured the WTO
process to benefit them so I i think
it's it's very important that this
should not be allowed that the trade
expansion mechanism and that world trade
should benefit everyone and particularly
the poorest people and should not be
captured by special interests backed by
the rich countries so this is this is
one of the themes that we need to
develop I'm not enter trade I think
trade is a beneficial thing it helps
growth it can help poverty eradication
but it must be governed like finance
like other areas by an international
governance system that is much more
democratic and much more oriented
towards development and were the people
from the developing countries have a
much greater say
so are you then saying that the trip the
trade related in the intellectual
property issue should not be actually
raised in GWT or it should be raised but
the way it was done and even they lived
you know very free trade economists like
Jagdish Bhagwati for example agree with
this the way it was done is to restrict
access action to medical products and to
the production of medical products in
the poor countries and raised the cost
for the poor people and I think 22 a
degree that is not justified of course
intellectual property rights have to be
protected up to a certain point one
should reward people who do the research
and we invent new products but how much
and how long yeah and you know who
should bear the cost and who should pay
the cost for this I think it should be
monopoly profits of these companies or
should it perhaps me a little bit the
taxpayer that contributes to some of
these costs I think these things need to
be discussed and the way the trips was
introduced I think reflected in a way
the international system at its worst
yeah and finally the question of
indebtedness has been very much debated
and people have been basically saying
complete debt relief to the poor
countries but also emerging economies do
have quite sizable debt like even Turkey
has right seventy percent of GDP will
date so how do you resolve that nagging
sort of debt issue that sort of spreads
from the poorest Ravi yeah it's a big
issue of course in the poorest countries
it's a debilitating issue and I think
the international community now is
finally doing more for the first country
debt but as you say it's not just the
poorest country Brazil has a huge debt
burden of course Turkey has it any other
countries Philippines has it other Latin
American countries have large debt
burdens and some of that debt has been
accumulated due to the excessive
volatility in international capital
markets you had periods not now interest
rates are quite low
now but there were periods were all of a
sudden interest rates shut up not
because of anything Mexico did or turkey
did but because of something the Federal
Reserve did or you know in something
that happened in Europe particularly if
we recall that the big debt crisis of
the early 1980s so it's a collective
promising it's too easy to say well if
you've got that you must have really
misbehaved in the past sometimes the
misbehavior has been on the part of the
lenders who rushed in and then you know
overwhelm the country with with with
credit so to speak and without actually
also channeling into the best to the
best sectors the most productive
investments so the responsibility for
that is is shared often and we must look
at the debt problem from that point of
view of course International Capital
Markets can bring additional resources
and we should work with them we should
not lock our doors to international
flows not at all but I think we should
manage the debt in a much more proactive
way what's the explanation but well the
recommendation is that for the poorest
countries there really should be
forgiveness on a large scale
particularly because some of these that
also were very political you know the
audio stet problem in the old days when
there was still the Cold War you would
give you know you will give that to your
friends without really looking at how
they used it did they use it for their
own people or did they divert it into
their own pockets or both arms with it
so this kind of debt you know I think we
should create a clean clean slate for
the other types of debts in the in there
in the middle income countries such as
Brazil Turkey they should be built down
over time and I think the international
institutions the IMF the World Bank
should should accompany this effort by
providing longer-term funds at lower
costs that's one of the proposals in my
book that so long that well not very
soft not as soft as for Africa or so but
there should be reasonably low interest
rates on long-term resources that can be
used for poverty reduction also in these
countries we have to remember
that a country like Brazil for example
you know has huge numbers of poor people
very very poor people and therefore they
should not suffer from the macroeconomic
stabilization efforts that are needed
now of course this should be done over a
long period this cannot be solved
overnight there's no magic solution but
if we work on it together and if we
recognize the problem and don't simply
say that it's all the fault of these
countries but if we work internationally
in solving this problem I think we can
make progress this also has to come with
some conditionality yes I wise yes sup
lon will disappear yes I am NOT against
conditionality I think there have to be
governance related conditionalities
economic and social policy related
conditionalities for example if there's
going to be a subsidy that benefits to
some degree from international support
it should go to the poor people not to
vested interest that kind of
conditionality I think is needed but you
see for conditionality to be accepted
when we come back to the beginning of
our chat today these institutions have
to be perceived as truly legitimate as
truly international and also owned and
supported by the developing countries
and so you see it's all linked if you
want to have good condition allottee you
have the legitimacy but how do you when
you have seven rich country basically
dictating terms how do you make them
take a little less prominent role allow
other countries to payroll how do you do
that at the Indy in the data logs
institutions like the fam farm and the
bank well I think in the end you know
the world is interdependent a stronger
india more rapidly growing brazil or
turkey or a better economic situation
africa helps everyone including the g7
countries crisis lack of security
failure in governance mechanisms breeds
disease breeds terror
breathes environmental degradation
increasingly I think the citizens of the
world realize and the young people more
than the others perhaps realize that
their future is interlinked and
therefore I do believe if you want to
have good policies and legitimacy then
the citizens in the richer countries
have to agree to share not give up
totally because they also had deserved
you know influence and and and certain
abilities to influence events but it has
to be shared better and I think in the
enlightened interest of the rich
countries themselves indicate that there
is need for reform there is need for
sharing there is need for more
democratic international system
everybody will benefit from it in the
long run and I think that's the message
solving a better you know globalization
thank you very much Paul Darvish thank
you thanks for having me thank you